OK, why don't we go next to
Calvin from Colorado. Calvin,
are you glad to have the all
star game coming your way?
Yes, I am good. What's on your mind? Yeah,
so I'm just thinking about the infrastructure
bill. Yep. And. It's pretty expensive, and
Kirsten Gillibrand today tweeted out that,
you know, paid leave. And childcare and caregiving
are all infrastructure. Do you agree with that?
I don't know. I'd have to think about
that. I mean, OK, so obviously roads
and bridges nobody disagrees with. That's
infrastructure, electrical grid, broadband,
green energy. Many people, but not everybody on
the right agrees. Our infrastructure, child care
and paid leave. I mean, listen, if we I have
no problem getting it done via infrastructure.
No problem whatsoever, is it infrastructure in the
same way as some of this other stuff? I mean, I
guess the argument in favor would be that you are
enabling many systems, including raising children,
because you're able to take time off from work
without losing money. You're enabling many systems
to work better. You're helping the educational
system. You're helping, you know, cultures like
you can make the argument. I don't know that it's
it's super obvious to me. But if we can be done
through infrastructure, I'm glad to do it that
way. I'd have to read more about it, I think.
Right, I, I try to take a really holistic
view on infrastructure, and I, I think they're
on the right track.
Yeah, yeah. I mean, let's see what can
be done. I think that's also another question. At
what point does it become impossible to get done?
And I don't know what the answer is, but you're
definitely going to need all Democrats on board.
My question I question whether family
leave appeals to all 50 Democrats in
the Senate as part of an infrastructure
bill, I don't know that it does. Yeah,
OK, Calvin from Colorado, thank you
very much for the call, I appreciate it.